we're gonna play spin the bottle we
don't know what this but it's supposed
to be fun
you're supposed to turn off your TV in
this game it's kind of weird
each round a player spins the ball and
is assigned a partner the pair must
complete random challenge complete the
challenge to win a flower sauce kneel
like a lumberjack
there is no sir no the remotes together
and saw right or wrong sorry
each partner holes jump together
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that's two section blind dog
welfare sit on the floor one is
blindfolded what the hell nice thanks
guys Oh press a and B on the bone do not
knock it over okay straight right oh
wait I'll ask for you
we're here
no I not throw away oh that's make sure
it's ending up right yeah right where
the hell in there what balance challenge
each other balancing the remotes between
your arms sit down fully on the floor
and get up again with that we're
supposed to do now
mr. ball beach tennis
you ready
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm like Ambari over here
squeeze the orange plays an orange
between you and we're squeezing your
suppose we've gotta get old orange yes
hope you enjoyed watching has been do
awkward stuff together
I can only imagine if you do this with
like people you don't know enough like
that me so yeah look like you're
watching this guy come breath today and
we'll see you but I'll see if we're too
late peace punch what how am I supposed
to dance
leave leave that laughs Anthony why are
they singing in German
[Music]